>> THIS IS WHAT I CAN'T BELIEVE.
AND YOU ARE THEIR STAR WITNESS.
JOINING ME NOW IS JEFF SESSIONS,
FORMER ATTORNEY GENERAL, AND IT
NOW AGAIN FOR A U.S. SENATE OF
ALABAMA.
WHAT IS YOUR BIG TAKE AWAY FROM
TODAY?
>> IT CERTAINLY TO ME -- I AGREE
WITH KEN STARR.
THIS IS A VERY SERIOUS TIME FOR
AMERICA.
IT DOES NOT APPEAR TO ME THAT
THEY HAVE THE KIND OF EVIDENCE
THAT WOULD JUSTIFY GOING
FORWARD.
I CALLED IT A SHOW TRIAL.
WHAT'S A SHOW TRIAL?
WHEN YOU DECIDED THAT LOOKS
GUILTY.
AND THIS IS THE KIND OF THING
THAT I THINK IS CONCERNING TO A
LOT OF PEOPLE.
THE CONSTITUTION SAYS
IMPEACHMENT IS NOT ANYTHING
CONGRESS SAYS IT IS, IT SAYS
IT'S FOR CONVICTION OF TREASON
AND BRIBERY, HIGH CRIMES AND
MISDEMEANORS.
THOSE ARE RESTRAINING LAWS IN
OUR CONSTITUTION THAT RESTRAINS
CONGRESS AND THEY NEED TO BE
FAITHFUL TO THEIR
RESPONSIBILITIES AND,
FUNDAMENTAL ANALYSTS URGE OUR
DEMOCRATIC MEMBERS OF CONGRESS
TO THINK DEEPLY ABOUT THE FUTURE
OF THIS COUNTRY AND THE DANGER
TO THIS REPUBLIC THAT WOULD
OCCUR IF WE CONTINUE TO
PROSECUTE PEOPLE BASICALLY
BECAUSE WE DON'T LIKE THEM OR WE
HAVE A POLITICAL DISAGREEMENT.
>> Laura: SENATOR, WHAT MORE
CAN THE MEMBERS OF REPUBLICAN
PARTY SERVING IN CONGRESS TODAY
DO FOR THIS PRESIDENT AND FOR
HIS AGENDA THAT THEY ARE NOT
DOING PERHAPS?
MAYBE A LITTLE ADVICE OF WHAT
THEY CAN DO BETTER OR MORE TO
HELP THIS ADMINISTRATION?
>> WE HAVE TO TAKE THE CASE TO
THE PEOPLE.
BASED ON ALL THE ISSUES HE'S
ADVOCATING, STANDING UP TO
CHINA, BEING PART OF THE
DEPLOYMENT, ON THIS IMPEACHMENT,
I THINK THEY'VE GOT TO SPEAK OUT
PRETTY AGGRESSIVELY AND SAY,
WHERE'S THE BEEF.
WHAT IS THE CHARGE.
DOES IT MEET THE CONSTITUTIONAL
STANDARDS AND, I THINK WE HAVE A
LOT OF MEMBERS THAT ARE.
SO REPUBLICANS NEED TO BE
CONFIDENT THAT IF THE EVIDENCE
DOES NOT SUPPORT IMPEACHMENT
THEY WILL THEY ARE PERFECTLY
SAFE.
>> SENATOR, ARE YOU IN
RETROSPECT, WE ALL LOOK BACK ON
DECISIONS WE MADE.
ARE YOU GLAD YOU LEFT THE SENATE
TO GO WORK IN THE SENATE
ADMINISTRATION?
>> I DON'T LOOK BACK ON THOSE
KIND OF MATTERS.
WE MADE A DECISION I THOUGHT WAS
RIGHT AT THE TIME AND A LOT OF
PEOPLE THINK ALL WE DID WAS DEAL
WITH RUSSIA BUT WE HAD A
TREMENDOUS REVITALIZATION OF
FEDERAL CRIMINAL PROSECUTIONS
THROUGHOUT THE COUNTRY.
HER REVITALIZATION OF
PARTNERSHIPS WITH OUR STATE AND
LOCAL ALLIES.
WE STOOD OUT FOR RELIGIOUS
LIBERTY AND WE HELP TO THE
PRESIDENT APPOINT THE BEST GROUP
OF FEDERAL JOINTED STOMACH
JUDGES THAT HAD EVER BEEN
APPOINTED.
THERE WAS SO MUCH, WE STARTED A
NEW GROUP TO INTENSIFY OUR
EFFORTS TO PROSECUTE FRAUD AND
THE I.T. NETWORKS AND
PARTICULARLY CHINA.
A LOT OF GOOD THINGS OCCURRED,
AND I KNEW A LOT ABOUT IT BUT I
FELT LIKE WE WERE DOING A
GOOD JOB.
WE HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO SEEK
THE SENATE SEAT AGAIN AND I
WOULD BE PLEASED.
>> IF YOU COULD -- THE PRESIDENT
VOCATIONALLY WATCHES THE SHOW,
ANYTHING YOU'D LIKE TO SAY TO
THEM TONIGHT?
>> HE DIDN'T HAVE A BETTER
SUPPORTER IN THE UNITED STATES
SENATE THEN WHEN I WAS THERE.
I WAS HIS FIRST SUPPORTER IN THE
UNITED STATES SENATE, BUT, --
WHAT DO YOU SAY TO THOSE
REPUBLICANS?
THIS PRESIDENT, HE'S NOT A REAL
CONSERVATIVE.
HE'S NOT REALLY DOING THE
CONSERVATIVE THING.
HE'S NOT BRINGING THE MOVEMENT
ALONG, HE SPENDING TOO MUCH TIME
ON THE SIDE FIGHTS.
WHAT DO YOU SAY TO THEM?
>> I TELL YOU THIS PRESIDENT HAS
MOVED A CONSERVATIVE AGENDA IN A
HOST OF AREAS.
HE CUT TAXES.
ISN'T THAT CONSERVATIVE?
HE STANDS UP FOR AMERICA FIRST
THROUGHOUT THE WORLD.
ISN'T THAT GOOD?
DEFENDING AMERICAN MANUFACTURING
AGAINST CHEATING BY CHINA, I
KNOW THE COUNTRY.
HE'S TRYING TO DEFEND OUR
BORDERS AND THAT'S A WAY THAT
AFFECTS THE RULE OF LAW IN
AMERICA.
I JUST THINK HE'S BEEN
CONSERVATIVE CONSISTENTLY.
BUT MOST IMPORTANTLY, HE'S BEEN
EFFECTIVE AND FAITHFUL IN WHAT
HE PROMISED.
HE TOLD THE AMERICAN PEOPLE WHAT
HE WOULD DEAL, AND A LOT OF
PEOPLE DOUBTED HE WOULD DO IT,
BUT HE'S DONE IT BETTER THAN
ALMOST ANY PRESIDENT IN A MY
LIFETIME.
>> Laura: AND SENATOR, I KNOW
HE HAD SOME CHOICE WORDS FOR YOU
MOSTLY BECAUSE OF THE MUELLER
DEAL AND ROSENSTEIN.
BUT DO YOU THINK YOU WILL
ULTIMATELY GET HIS ENDORSEMENT?
>> I HOPE SO.
CERTAINLY I'M GOING TO WORK FOR
THAT AND WE WILL BE SEEKING IT.
HE DOESN'T ALWAYS GET INVOLVED
IN PRIMARY SO I UNDERSTAND THAT
AND HE HAS INDICATED HE PROBABLY
WOULD NOT IN THIS ONE.
BUT YES.
I WOULD LOVE TO HAVE HIS
SUPPORT.
I ASK PEOPLE FIRST, I HAVE SOME
PEOPLE OF ALABAMA AND THROUGHOUT
THE COUNTRY TO TRUST HIM AND
SUPPORT HIM.
I THOUGHT HE WAS THE ONE WHO
COULD WIN AND IF YOU WIN, I
THOUGHT HE COULD BRING THAT
DRIVE, THAT ENERGY, THAT WILL
BECAUSE IT'S EXTRAORDINARY, TO
ADVANCE HIS AGENDA.
>> Laura: YOU ARE ABSOLUTELY
RIGHT.